[Música]
aquí
una bebida que está viva
y se ha convertido en una tendencia a
nivel mundial de consumirlas
pero con una bebida puede estar viva
es porque esta bebida está preparada con
un proceso de fermentación con un hongo
bacteriano y este hongo es una cultura
viva hoy en día se consumen productos
fermentados por temas de salud por eso
dicen que el futuro experimentado cuando
pensamos en adicciones se nos viene
nuestra mente drogas alcohol sexo redes
sociales que es muy común ahora también
están los juegos de azar
pero en sí una adicción es todo aquello
que nos gusta tanto que nos convierte en
esclavos
pero por qué hablar de este tema
muchos de nosotros y me incluyo vivimos
con adicciones tal vez no de vicios como
las drogas o el alcohol pero se han
puesto a pensar en las comidas y bebidas
hay muchos centros donde podemos acudir
cuando hay una adicción de alcohol por
ejemplo pero qué pasa cuando somos
adictos a las comidas y bebidas con un
alto contenido de azúcar a donde
acudimos amor gerland claro que no 800
mil hondureños padecen de diabetes tipo
2 según la secretaria de salud de
nuestro país
422 millones de personas a nivel mundial
tienen esta enfermedad también según la
organización mundial de la salud es
alarmante y debemos de preocuparnos por
esto
he oído esa frase que dice que nuestro
cuerpo es nuestro templo que lo dañamos
con lo que comemos y con lo que bebemos
entonces por qué es seguir con malos
hábitos de alimentación
porque se dice que el futuro es
fermentado si es parte del pasado y está
en nuestro presente
la fermentación es una de las
biotecnologías más antiguas para la
producción de este tipo de alimentos que
deseamos que tengan una prolongación de
su vida útil y buenas propiedades
organolépticas que quiere decir que va a
tener su olor y su sabor como en
intensidad que el de un alimento normal
le voy a poner un ejemplo si tenemos una
zanahoria cruda y una zanahoria
fermentada en un encurtido que creo que
nos gustan bastante la zanahoria y el
encurtido va a tener una mayor impresión
sensorial por su proceso de fermentación
este tipo de alimentos tienen una
estabilidad microbiana mejorada y segura
por lo que por lo tanto su
y su almacenamiento puede también estar
a temperatura ambiente como el caso del
encurtido que les mencionaba
[Música]
el consumo de los productos fermentados
se remonta al principio de nuestra vida
con el suelo nuestro amor por el alcohol
para los que no saben nace inocentemente
del consumo de frutas caídas de los
árboles que estaban en un proceso de
fermentación
y hay información de fermentación
controlada en países como china desde
hace siete mil años
esto es milenario en el antiguo egipto
3000 años y si hablamos de culturas
prehispánicas tenemos el ejemplo de
méxico que se utiliza que dan esto este
proceso de fermentación controlada desde
hace 2000 años también en la medicina
ayurveda que es conocida en india se
conocen datos de que hace milenios
utilizan los alimentos fermentados y en
algunas religiones se consideraba
incluso sagrados yo creo que aquí el más
común que hemos probado es el yogur que
lo encontramos en los supermercados pero
hay más allá del yogur que nos puede
servir en nuestra alimentación
ya que hoy en día debido al nivel de
toxicidad que estamos sometidos se nos
convierte como en una necesidad de
encontrar un alimento que nos des beaux
y que ya sea un jugo verde o cualquier
otra cosa que nosotros nos haga sentir
mejor en nuestro organismo por eso es
importante conocer cuáles son estos
alimentos que nos pueden ayudar a
mejorar y hacer una digestión
es aquí donde entra una bebida
que yo conocí cuando estudie me
certifique como sommelier detective
andar en el 2016 con hostil sobre el
proceso de la convulsa que es una bebida
100% natural muchas veces orgánica y que
está elaborada a base de té y del hongo
bacteriano que les mencionaba al
principio que es una cultura viva
el proceso de esta fermentación nos
brinda una variada gama de enzimas
minerales ácidos orgánicos esenciales
probióticos creo que la palabra
probióticos muchos las escuchamos y no
sabemos realmente qué significan los
probióticos lo que hacen es que cuando
entran en nuestro cuerpo empiezan a
trabajar en nuestro sistema digestivo
para ayudarnos a acelerar el proceso de
la digestión
entonces ahora ustedes que ya conocen
tienen tenemos que informarnos más qué
tipo de alimentos nos pueden ayudar a ir
mejorando nuestros hábitos alimenticios
la con mucha es un monte
que se fermenta con este hongo llamado
scoring este té contiene una simbiosis
de levaduras y aceto bacterias dentro de
las conocidas están la bacterias y linus
y de las levaduras pues en el proceso
varían pero las más conocidas son la
cándida este lata y la psico sacaron
misses bomba
este es el hongo
que se utiliza para realizar la bebida
y aquí tenemos lo que son las bacterias
las levaduras que contiene en la bebida
lo que hacen es que el azúcar que
ponemos dentro del té para prepararla lo
convierte en glucosa y fructosa después
pasa a ser alcohol etílico y termina con
un gas carbónico al final tenemos una
bebida cero azúcar carbonatada
naturalmente y que nos ayuda porque
tiene probióticos
para prepararla en casa es muy fácil
necesitamos un bote de vidrio un buen té
de base ya sea un té negro siempre y
cuando sea de la planta camellia
sinensis té negro té blanco este verde
té azul
y un bote de vidrio azúcar el té y por
supuesto el hongo es joven si ustedes se
fijan en este bote tenemos nosotros el
honguito adentro está el té y ha
preparado
entonces para comenzar el proceso dura
entre 7 y 14 días el proceso de la
primera fermentación hacemos el té
normal suponiendo que hay un té negro lo
endulzamos obviamente hay una receta
para las cantidades lo endulzamos con
azúcar puede ser azúcar morena o azúcar
normal no puede ser panela porque el
hongo necesita el azúcar de verdad para
alimentarse y hacer todo el proceso
entonces colocamos el azúcar endulzamos
el té cuando está a temperatura ambiente
nos lavamos bien nuestras manos no
utilizando guantes colocamos el hongo
adentro
un té y ha fermentado que es una
cantidad pequeña lo tapamos si ustedes
se fijan él tiene
es como un filtro de papel o puede ser
una gasa o una tela delgada porque el
hongo necesita como es una cultura viva
necesita respirar para reproducirse y
para hacer todo el proceso de las
bacterias y de las levaduras
entonces lo dejamos a temperatura
ambiente donde no le entre luz donde no
le entre color porque se puede
contaminar como el cuarto día
necesitamos medirle el ph el ph lo que
hace es medir el nivel de acidez
mientras el hongo más se coma el azúcar
que colocamos en el té más ácido se va a
hacer por eso el nivel de acidez va a
depender del gusto de cada quien por eso
el tiempo es entre 7 y 14 días yo lo
dejo 7 días porque a mí me gusta no está
nacido entonces medimos el ph que está
entre 2 y 4 hay unas banditas especiales
de papel para medir las si pasa a número
5 que quiere decir que nuestra kombucha
fue contaminada y debemos desechar
completamente el humo y todo el líquido
y volver a empezar el proceso si está
entre 2 y 4 está perfecto como el
séptimo día
nosotros en el bote podríamos observar
con una luz un foco podemos ver que el
hongo que introducimos se fue al fondo y
se formó uno nuevo en la superficie eso
quiere decir que el proceso está muy
bien porque se está reproduciendo entre
cada uva se forma una pequeña telita que
es como el cordón umbilical entre la
mamá y el hijo porque el hongo madre fue
el primero y el hongo hijo es el que
nace en la superficie es como un
embarazo porque porque estos hongos son
una cultura viva cuando terminamos la
primera fermentación retiramos los dos
hongos con mucho cuidado del líquido
guardamos un poco del líquido fermentado
también y el té que nos queda fermentado
en el bote lo colocamos en botellas de
vidrio y podemos hacer una segunda
fermentación para darle sabor ya sea con
algunas frutas ya sea con alguna flor o
podemos utilizar alguna raíz como el
jengibre y ya depende del gusto de cada
quien
nosotros sin bacterias enfermamos esto
es un trabajo en equipo ustedes han
escuchado cuando dicen que el niño que
juega a tierra o que está expuesto a un
ambiente lleno de bacterias es menos
propenso a enfermarse es porque es
cierto necesitamos las bacterias para
que nuestro cuerpo cree defensas por eso
es importante preservar un entorno o un
sistema bacteriano seguro
cuando me convertí en mamás
me puse a pensar en la importancia
de cambiar mis hábitos alimenticios
porque esto lo que hace es prolongar
nuestros años de vida
donde podríamos nosotros habitar fuera
de nuestro cuerpo
alguien puede prestar unos unos y
enfermamos creo que no
es por eso que voy a cerrar este tema
con una frase famosa de buda que dice el
problema es que crees que tienes tiempo
yo los invito a dar el paso oye no
esperemos a estar enfermos para comenzar
a mimar nuestro cuerpo con cosas
saludables
así que
a tomar con muchas y a comer saludable
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]